austin do you want to be on the wheel
the week before you come in studio as a
possible cats after dark fight club
participant
one thousand percent i love schneiderlin
that's that's the only answer we we
would have excited
type of promoter or something that's
going to fix the fight so we can work
something out because i can win 100
it's a it's a smart thing to try but i
i'm afraid if you get matched up with me
it's going to be austin asleep
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back
to another cats after dark the big three
you know us we're here every week the
original crew yeah different day
bringing it bring in the hot hot
behind-the-scenes thick boy action to
you we've got a really fun show today
we're gonna do the first playing round
of the cats trivia contest can't wait
for that we're gonna zoom in austin and
austin who are out in georgia filming a
music video uh we're gonna talk about
some fights uh but before we do that
we gotta talk about our spans the
sponsors that's the answer
that catch my catch was incredible that
was a bad toss it was all good i got it
our sponsor magic mind and i don't know
if you guys saw that catch it was pretty
incredible and that's because i've been
taking my i didn't take mine yet that's
why i didn't catch mine i didn't take
mine that's why i was a bad throw there
you go it's honestly uh
during my weight cut you know i haven't
been eating that much or treating myself
to anything that tastes good so this is
really like my dessert for the day uh
magic mind is the once daily shot the
the magical elixir with 12 natural
ingredients that will help you do more
and stress less uh you've been getting a
lot more done since you've been taking
magic might happen i got a time we were
able to write songs now it helps your
mind it really does makes you creative
yeah it's uh it's changed my life uh i
know we've had a lot of listeners out
there order it and try it we want to
hear about your
experience with magic mind so email the
show dm the show dm any one of us
individually and if you can show us a
rece receipt for magic mind we'll bring
in the show
uh learned a little bit about you and
hear about your experience with matt
share us share with us your magic
memories oh i like that i like that a
lot so if you want to try it go to
magicmind.com use promo code dark for 20
off that's
magicmind.com use promo code dark for 20
off i look good i do too
thank you magic mind thanks guys all
right let's should we get in this show
let's do it let's get rid of these so
for uh um continuity's sake uh what's
been going on chin what have you been up
to the last week let's see i went
camping once again shocking shocker but
it's only for one night so big bear
uh my cousin went my brother went my
cousin's kid went so it's like a good
family time oh yeah oh yeah anything out
of the organ happen bear attack
you know the funny thing is i posted a
video because i was promoting that tea
again yeah so i posted a video
and then the majority of the comments
are like how disgusting the water look
they look like a nuclear power plant or
waste management plant and it actually
does look like terrible can you bring up
that picture that's like a real oh my
instagram it's like the most recent one
yeah
um
because i guess i didn't i guess maybe i
didn't watch the reel but i saw some
picture and it looked like exactly like
what was on the shirt
definitely not but
there it is right there oh now i see it
looks horrible right
what the shirt the shirt is like there's
water there's blue water but that's like
look at the background it looks so
terrible when i look at it that's so
funny
and then plus like the dam looks like
actual like a waste thing or yeah yeah
nuclear site it's like something in the
simpsons or something where that's what
someone said yeah and you're just like
three-eyed fish or something
it's so funny dude
that was it
and that's
that's not impact font is it yeah okay
get off impactful dude this is the
simplest easiest it's easy on the eyes
it's easy on the eyes babe yeah i
actually just tweeted this weekend stop
using impact font i look at like uh like
two years ago when because it's a it is
a very basic one within premiere they
they only have a few and you're like oh
i just want something
it's a strong gold yeah
but the impact it has an impact but now
i recognize it so much and i see like
clips i made of theo right when i first
started that's all impactfun and i'm
like i hate it i've started going to a
different direction especially i see
like these big youtubers like really big
youtubers and they're using the simplest
regular like aerial font but with the
impact i put like um an outline yeah
width and all that stuff shade this is
some insight basically i i could i could
talk fonts all day everybody check out
the
doc helvetica on youtube it's really
riveting stuff
first of all i see knockout
featherweight is what i'm into and i now
see it everywhere it's very skinny
knockout featherweight yeah this past
weekend can you bring up the this past
weekend logo
um is that uh on instagram or just the
this past weekend logo
uh it's it's a it's a pretty simple
clean it's skinny so you can get a lot
in on words that's yeah yeah that's not
good you'll see that a lot it's funny
when you notice there there's only so
many fonts yeah
i mean there's a sh i mean
i have final cut there's a gazillion but
only there's only a few that i want to
use yeah yeah
they get too crazy with them and stuff
uh man some people turned it off but
again i'm riveted by font selection i i
have to tell you um
but i think people might be more hyped
on the font talk than they were our
fight chin
did you see the response i well i heard
it from our crew but yeah uh well they
they they're saying like we it was like
they want their money back even though
it's free or something yeah it's just
super funny yeah it's that's that's fair
but uh actually it's not because i will
say
shin and i went to war for your
entertainment uh we laid our life out
online
and
i don't i don't people were calling
click bait uh pillow punches that was
actually christian but
you people don't know what you were
seeing
this is what floyd mayweather had to go
through his entire life uh
we try to hit him with some good [ __ ]
don't get hit and go home with a
pocketful of cash yeah just like nate
diaz and that's what we did it's the
sweet science it was a beautiful display
of defensive boxing i mean
on your part yeah yeah right
that one slip you yours i mean i guess
you did just kind of uh
you wrote me in you kind of a
rope-a-dope just letting me wear myself
out on your body because you wore gas
out you were pretty damn guessed up but
i'm thinking now i'm not even kidding i
think now i i feel like we kind of don't
want to hurt each other that bad
if we get matched up again or in the
next one if i match up with like let's
say george
then i think i'm just going to go like
yeah not hard hard hard but actually
going for it and i know you don't wear
headgear but i think with the headgear
people might feel less bad about it i
don't know and it's just like you spar
no one's when people do spar
at like they're not trying to hurt each
other trying to get better and stuff
yeah you gotta go that level
um and it'll be more fun for the fans i
guess even though i thought like i said
if you knew what you were seeing
educated viewers i really enjoyed it we
only had one camera angle two right so
if they saw all the angles they'll
realize how good it was yeah yeah travis
just text me oh nice diddy
um
yeah see if phil's cfl zoom in
um travis parker
but yeah i thought it was a beautiful
display of boxing uh by both of us
people shouldn't complain it's gonna get
better i will say that um and yeah if
you did thought that was clickbait you
don't again just you don't know what
you're saying you don't know you didn't
see well it's our fault we we're gonna
we'll have more than one camera next
time probably so you can see the sweet
science yeah yeah from different angles
we had we had the gopro a little bit but
the the the mic was blocking
the the production's improving uh every
day but and our ring is kind of small
but you know
i like it i like this that's another
complaint here people are like you got
to get out of there and uh and it's
someone's gonna get hurt it's too small
of an area
in my opinion there'd be no greater
honor than to go out like million dollar
baby and crack my head on on the desk
that i designed and and died that way
well
we're all gonna die when we're 80 anyway
so hey not 80.
around yeah whatever
but so
i don't know i'm excited about to come
bro supposed to be fighting brows uh but
he's ducking what up freaking brows dude
we are gonna uh zoom him in austin in
from atlanta later uh their music video
should i see if they're both available
right now yeah
um austin awake him they did that song
together arizona which is catching the
world by storm is it yeah it's actually
when they put it out it's like 140 views
or 140 000 views in like two days just
on spotify no on youtube oh the spotify
streams are like probably crazy yeah oh
wow that's awesome but but the video
they're shooting isn't they shot that
yeah they already shot arizona yeah
they're
uh just the grind doesn't stop they're
shooting another one in atlanta
yeah i mean brows have like two songs
coming out
i don't like to say it who's coming out
soon so never mind but we're working on
two songs we've already got it down
pretty pretty high nice yeah you guys
i i kind of gave you guys [ __ ] for the
release dates and stuff are always vague
but it's hard you don't know when yeah
but you're always working on stuff yeah
i hate honestly i used to say that way
back in the day but i hate nowadays when
people like new music coming out soon
i'm like just tell me when it's out and
then put it out that day
that's a thing i caught myself i take it
back that's the thing that you see from
creators the announcement of the
announcement i know
we're guilty we're gonna have big news
coming soon uh i i want to uh just let
everybody know that cats after dark
in two weeks we're going to be dropping
some news about some news that's going
to be coming and dude it's huge it's big
it's big oh man can't wait can't wait
for you guys to find out yeah because
we're gonna find the same time uh also
in a little bit we're finally gonna have
our very first round it's gonna be a
little different from the regular format
so we're gonna do the ultimate cats fan
uh contest i took out trivia from the
word because i've decided i'm gonna
change the games they may some will be
king and sting trivia some will be like
more podcasts
the whole podcast world and maybe some
other games where they'll kind of like
select someone in studio to be like
their their like
wolf contest i got a whole thing going
on my mind really working on this
weekend but today we have nine people
currently and we're gonna whittle down
so we have eight and
basically we reached out to the two
contestants who had the lowest effort
essentially submission
and why
because
those are kind of the
one of those guys is going to be the odd
man now and not be in the actual eight
man tournament since they didn't they
didn't put a ton of effort in they have
to take one more step to be in the
official contest um so we got a couple
things lined up for them to to whittle
them down
um
and if once we get them on
i'll try to think of what that is
no actually what i want to do it's going
to be very simple we're going to we're
going to meet these guys
and i want to play a name game of people
who have been king
ever and that's actually really good and
the the first person to get someone
wrong or name someone who's on it is out
it's pretty simple but uh we we gotta
get
people keep going like oh what is this
like the the vinyl album is this never
gonna happen uh the trivia contest and
so we gotta get it going this week yeah
on this quick way to do it and it's like
it's actually a really daunting task
trying to like put together the
tournament and make them interesting and
like make the questions funny but
something i'm working on
i mean we could all like chip in and
help just let us know yeah uh yeah yeah
i'm i'm down i need to do a better job
of that um
i just want everybody to be in my head
and know what i'm thinking and yeah
i i don't want to be in your head
definitely you're in there enough
uh
and then what was the other oh big fight
weekend oh yeah
uh ufc 278
um i think camaro is going to lose his
title
what i do holy crap i i just think i
just think lee picks
we'll see what happens i mean i wouldn't
pick them straight up but at plus 300 i
put a little bit on them and i just
think leon back in the day like i mean
that was like seven years ago they don't
wrestle in england he's been working on
that for seven years camaro's getting
really old
he didn't get injured in his last fight
did he uh
he has like two really bad knees
apparently all the time
yeah yeah like apparently it's it's
tough for him just to even walk or go
upstairs but when he fights i guess the
adrenaline kicks in
see and he's just amazing uh so you
think usman as that is actually gonna
lose i i i kind of just feel like at
some point the age and like the wear and
tear that we just talked about will will
hit him and leon just seems to be in his
absolute prime and there is something
that there's like a burnout and i don't
know this has happened with camaro i
haven't really heard interviews with him
recently but like
connor talked about it really early on
and you you see it like
champions they win the championship they
don't have like a lot of limelight on
them but that first defense the media
run and the media tour you have to get
and then it's every defense after that
it becomes a way bigger thing than just
the fight and i think
these champions can get burnt out on it
like camaro doesn't seem like he loves
being in front of cameras and it only
gets more and more every fight um
whereas leon like he gets zero attention
yeah i feel like all that guy's doing
he's training but the the car the car is
fun besides that i mean
uh jose aldo marab
what do you got on that because i i
changed my mind on that i i
my biggest bet of the card is jose aldo
so you're picking jose yeah i was so
dewallashvili until i re-watched the
marilyn marios fight
and then
marlon rise basically took him any other
ref would probably stop the fight last
round but because he tired himself out
and then rob came back
you know that just showed me like okay
rob's stamina is great but when he gets
tagged who which jose is like
the master at yeah yeah and jose can go
for a while now especially this new
weight class yeah he could go for a
while the new weight class uh he's went
five like that that fight against rob
font was five rounds
and the pace was insane and this is only
three um obviously marab never get uh
gets tired and moravia has great
takedowns but he's not great at keeping
people down a lot like that's why you'll
see him he'll have like seven takedowns
in a fight because he has to keep taking
him down whereas jose aldo has
incredible takedown defense i just feel
like it's almost like the perfect
matchup for jose
and the worst matchup for murab because
i think there's a he's going to beat a
ton of guys in that division i would
that marlon rice i lost so much money on
marlon rice i was a huge fan of him he
was so badass in the beginning yeah and
then he because he came for a world
series of fighting he had stopped
multiple fights by leg kicks uh he was
the champion there and then he came over
he lost what i thought uh was i thought
he won in his ufc debut against rafael
sun sao so then he had to kind of like
keep working his way up and then i bet
him against cejudo he was doing great in
that fight first round and then he
gasped he was doing great against marab
gas there was there's another one it's
it's kind of like i don't know same old
thing with him every time but then you
see him you see him actually like wilt
and get broken
and it's like i'm sure we could see that
the fighters see that coaches see that
okay just keep going the cejudo fight
was like a great example of that because
they just kept clinching and like in the
beginning it was all marlin he had all
of it but then they just kept clinching
and you just saw that turn and like
body knee neat body there's good stuff
though
uh one more i don't feel to cover those
other ones but paul acosta and
luke rockhold i would say uh sexiest
match up in ufc they're saying best bods
best looks yeah yeah i actually i spent
a lot of time like this uh on this last
night because i i saw a uh i saw a tweet
about it
and i hear my their ufc tweeted out
they're like is this the best looking
matchup in history
and so i went through all the i looked
at all all the fighters all the
rankings for each weight class
um and here's here's what i came up with
what i thought were other
challengers for the best looking
match-ups and i would like to prefer
this preface this all by saying no homo
no no homo
let's see
there we go
all right
so here here's some other dimes that
haven't fought other dimes uh carlos
ullberg he's this you uh he's like the
polynesian dude or something like that i
don't know what he is can you bring up
carlos ullberg i think he is
like trains with the stylebender
oh yeah yeah he is a city kickboxing guy
yeah
he sorry his name uh carlos ulbert
bolberg
uh but he's he hasn't been in the ufc
long enough so he hasn't been matched up
with any other dimes but i mean to be ul
b-e-r-g
i think yeah and i hope everybody here i
i prefer this with no homo but yeah he's
the best looking guy in the ufc in my
opinion he's definitely really good
looking yeah
he's that's crazy you're looking at my
tweets this is the next step on the list
michael chandler also hasn't fought any
dimes uh and then alan joban not in ufc
anymore but never fought another dime
uh he was i mean everybody knows he was
an armani model um i i think the ufc
doesn't like to waste their dimes
against each other probably not uh
that's like the first time then huh the
first time for men dimes to fight each
other uh not the first time so the i was
like looking at the other dimes that are
in league see if they thought those are
three that i think haven't fought
anymore i would say in history we have
gsp bisping
gsp is a really good looking guy yeah
bisping i got some pushback on this
tweet and if you look up with his old
skinhead look on like the ultimate
fighter no but if you look up like
michael bisping in the expendables or
whatever i mean that's a he's a good
looking guy yeah sure strong jaw
good hair
um so gsp bisping and then you have
bisping rock hold times two okay uh
uh
romero costa romero's a looker and
anybody who says it's the overall
package though right i know look up look
up joel romero his face straight up
man
come on bro
no look at yes that's the one
yep he's always [ __ ] there
romero young
you got to find this picnic
okay that's a younger
i'm saying it's got to be the overall
look
because his body counts for like
look at that i mean that's the one that
that's when you have oh yeah oh yeah he
had it he just added up that
shut up i wasn't looking
the one the very left top
yeah come on dude nick you got to type
then
that's what someone said to me on
twitter and then that one
i mean because it's the smile yeah
he does have dimples so it it's
controversial but yes so then and then
uh so romero costa if you call romero
rockhold but yeah i think costa rockhold
easily easily got the cake um
i'd love to hear some of your other
matchups oh drew dober's another dime oh
yeah i didn't realize that he's a sneaky
dime oh yeah he became a dime later on
if you look at his instagram it's it's
not sneaky and man i know yeah nowadays
i think he's he's got some well-quaffed
pictures but he hasn't really faced any
other dimes and unless brad riddell's
your type i just he doesn't really do it
for him
i know there's got to be other ones
though you know i think okay so this
might be a controversial one but paul
craig i think he's got good uh facial
features uh people have said i look like
paul craig
[Laughter]
sean brady
i i'm
i'm a brady guy all right i'm just i'm
actually looking at the right yeah
that's how i that's how i did it too and
then it's tough because like obviously a
lot of these guys are big hulking men
but they're not like
like paulo cost is just a different type
of pretty yeah yeah he's he's so you'll
look at a name you make oh he's a pretty
good looking guy but then you put him
right next to paul costume yeah
so we got ted and travis both yeah we
should probably switch the subject i'm
going to get a little [ __ ] for that
segment
yeah and then also mvp and uh oh yeah
bksc this weekend uh and there's a fight
companion for both yes 11 a.m fight
companion fake boy youtube channel oh
it's that early yeah oh no it's in
london so are you guys gonna is it going
are you guys going through ufc 278 yeah
dude it's going to be insane oh
it's literally because we have to get
you know production we gotta get it
early and then we're not leaving until
like freaking midnight so probably like
seven to midnight or something crazy
like that i hope i wonder if they're
gonna uh
have the boo be drinking booze from
the beginning
that could be because burke chrysler is
going to be bert crusher and matt
michonne is going to be for the first
one i think holy they're going to be
pounding and you know brenda's going to
pound yeah
um
seems like we don't have
sound well nice to meet you today oh
yeah you too man youtube is this your
first time ever calling in
uh calling in yeah i submitted a video
actually a while back on their first uh
patreon episode that got through travis
travis uh he that ted was just trying to
we got you guys now we can hear you uh
theodore teddy was just trying to flex
on you when he just asked that question
because he's been on the show like 87
times oh listen to him
i wanted to know a little first timer or
what i just want to know
oh yeah
this is my first time zooming in though
what up chin what up dog
good to finally talk to you first
i got the end of the am shirt you're
kidding
i rock it all the time dude appreciate
you man that's awesome thank you man
yes i love it
um yeah so guys you two along with a
third person who didn't get back to us
today um out of all our entries were the
lowest effort entries
so we are gonna now
yeah
so now we are going to whittle down
uh
we have currently nine people
you two are going to have a little
playing contest to see who is in the
final eight bracket and then next
episode we will actually start our
trivia contest
um first we want to get to
know a little bit about you uh travis
where are you from what do you do
and who's your favorite person on cats
after darkness
uh no i live in brighton colorado i
actually manage a pawn shop here
uh cash
i was i gotta go with my dude chin
oh thanks bro
all right teddy you win welcome to the
final eight
[Laughter]
i have more questions about the pawn
shop but before we get there let's learn
a little bit about teddy where are you
from uh and uh
tell us more about you
we've got stuff going on in the
background
it's all good once uh originally i'm
from uh small town illinois when you
hear uh when you hear theo talk about
his rural illinois stories
that is literally where i grew up he
talked about stark county illinois
that's where i grew up prince built 10
miles away so
uh that he talks he tells a couple of
jokes about uh tripping on lsd and
finding his way with his hands and
that's that's my stomping ground so uh
uh me i mow yards for myself shout out
moreland services um down here in st
augustine florida now oldest city in
america and um
my favorite dude
nick i've been talking to you and
messaging you for a while now dude so i
gotta go with you but chin i got your
shirt so it's tough dude
it's a pretty good time
i need to release a shirt how are you
doing on that you need to get some merch
dude i i know that someone someone made
like a mana wrist design a couple years
ago that i loved but i was like i don't
know where to sell but now there's all
these directions uh man of risk
it was like me at a computer just like
clearly gambling like that's perfect
lean over it was pretty funny um
uh the pawn shop like i said i have to
ask more uh do you get some pretty shady
characters walking in there you ever
are you ever like compelled to have to
like think this is stolen and
maybe i shouldn't take this or
or
you're like any i don't ask questions
all the time i
i would probably say i do that
once it twice a day i get some shady
people that are clearly
cracked out of their minds and you know
what's funny is i'm in the back in my
office right now just took a break got
the got the text i was like all right
let's do this but yeah i'd say uh once
or twice a day i gotta pass on some
stuff that people was like all right
well how does this thing work and
they're like uh
i don't know and they like one eyes open
one eye is closed they can't figure the
[ __ ] out so it's either that or a lot of
fake jewelry people try to bring in fake
jewelry all the time and i can just i
look at him be like nah get out of here
it's like and then they get crazy with
me it's like no you can go figure stuff
out outside it's it gets pretty crazy
sometimes yeah uh do you do you ever get
stuff brought in that you're like i'm
gonna take um i'm gonna buy this or like
this is for me oh
100
100 i i i'm i'm big into music chin
another reason why i like it but uh
i played drums on a regular basis that's
my thing but i i play bass and guitar
and all that and sometimes we get some
beautiful instruments coming in and
probably might i purchased a gibson les
paul from the uh 85 i believe and that's
probably my favorite guitar i just i
can't get enough of it it's it was
beautiful and because i work here i'm a
manager i got a sweet ass deal on it so
it's no complaints perfect dude i
remember the first time i actually held
the les paul picked it up
and how it felt it just felt like
freaking yeah heavy and it felt
important and strong
and like legendary
yep yeah you know when you feel when you
got it in your hands you know what you
got yeah it's cool
okay well that's really interesting i'd
love to ask you more questions about the
i really actually did think it was
interesting but uh i'd love to ask you
more questions about the lawns but how
about this how about if we have someone
uh uh from cats after dark hit up teddy
at morley what's it moreland uh
lawn care
if we if we if we get uh if you have
someone hit hit you up and say they
heard about cats after dark can they get
their lawn mowed for free one time
oh yeah definitely no no actually let's
say let's say if that happens if we can
get that reach from california to
florida i'll promote that [ __ ] for free
what city is it
sane augustine or palm coast please see
the oldest city in america look it up if
they're
interesting if there is someone
in the st augustine area and you have a
lawn hit up ted say you heard about cats
after dark and you get it for free
you're welcome
let's go
uh huh the other city was palm coast
yeah yeah yeah so out of those two words
yeah um okay so let's get to this
contest we've uh we've got something
very simple to see who and i've already
decided uh i haven't got permission but
i'm going to fly in one night in a hotel
whoever it is it'll be spirit uh if you
want to come in studio or the
it'll be the cheapest flight but i will
do that out of my own pocket uh for the
winner of this tournament so that's
what's at stake here um
okay so the the we're gonna play a
little name game
uh we can flip to see who goes first
but the name game is
people who have been on king and the
sting
okay
uh
let's see i'm how do we select damn i
had a coin earlier but i don't know
all right
oopsies oops his heads black his tail
uh
travis call in the air
wait i said oops his head yeah okay
call him here
you said tails no you okay just go for
it
okay
flip it again
all right tails tails it is okay you can
go first or second
i will go second
all right teddy
name game
you're just looking for a guest right
somebody that's been on with you guys or
i've been on king of the thing correct
and it obviously could be the whole no
holes can work too all right distefano
correct
you just go back and forth rapid fire
travis
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you
on king and the sting yeah stevie
yep that's good
correct
griffin when was chrysler on there
correct early days
it was about it was about a year ago uh
yeah last summer middle studio when i
first started working here
i'm gonna have to get a timer out we're
we'll go 15 seconds uh going forward
it's it's on you it's on you uh ted
it's on me
ten seconds damn
he says hosts count two
five seconds
post count two yep three seconds well
damn i almost i'm i'm just i almost said
to leah
that counts
uh we're we're gonna start we're gonna
start start from now with the 50
with the yeah with the 15 second uh
timer going
from last point on from this point on we
will count to leah host count so
you could say anybody
i thought this would go a lot longer but
uh um okay so we're starting again you
you said dalia deleo's off the board
back to travis officially 15 seconds if
you go past 15 seconds i'm sorry
and it begins
now
oh including host theo there you go
that's what we were we kind of were
hitting at
brandon
brandon all right
it's uh travis 15 seconds
ah [ __ ] five seconds
ah
you've seen the show right he said chin
does that count oh did he get he got it
in china okay there we go good job dude
ted 50 seconds on me yeah 15 seconds
chappelle
got it nice 15 seconds oh
that's a [ __ ] that was a good one
uh
nick
there it is 15 seconds ted now we're
rolling
yeah
there you go it's gonna be tough after
this
christian oh my there it is
proud
nice wow 15 seconds
travis
mark
count it
15 seconds ted
bradley martin
no bradley martin has not appeared on
king of the sting
he's been on fire
damn
which we appreciate that by the way yeah
uh
a a couple other acceptable answers
would have been um
can i keep going do i still got a little
time oh no you you that was that was
incorrect that was officially correct
travis wins travis is now in the in the
tournament
uh congrats travis
it kind of bro it kind of bumps me out
because of the dedication teddy has had
over the years
he deserves a spot for sure dude if you
got anybody fall out you let me know 100
100 and i we only have these people's
emails and i've only been reaching out
day of you know you guys didn't get a
lot of lead time so we could have an
injury uh and we could stop in someone
all right other people put me up on the
sub list
other people who would have counted um
baby unique oh yeah who remembers baby
unique
yeah they're like
everybody's like uh i wasn't there for
that
uh
uh let's see
you get a little bit of pressure and you
just start to crumble yeah yeah
especially
the are you garbage guys oh yeah that
was recent oh [ __ ]
yeah
we
yeah we've had
i was actually blanking too but
um i almost said josh wolfe has he been
on there i feel like he has no fighter
in the kid
yeah josh wolfe hasn't been on uh king
this thing
and
i don't know if this
if you guys are thinking this zooms
count because we had jelly
um yeah uh but good stuff guys uh we had
a blast ted we'll keep you involved with
the show uh and travis we will see you
in probably like four weeks because
we'll do the or we'll do the other other
rounds uh but we'll release the bracket
this week and and
i don't know keep keep going with this
yeah appreciate you guys support yeah
you guys are awesome thank you guys
see you guys
all right take care guys you guys
thanks guys
that was fun super fun
uh are austin them ready
oh yeah it looks like they should be
have you said oh you are just sending
that
that was fun pretty crushing pretty
pretty crushing for ted
uh
you could see it in his face like he was
he was like bummed especially when i
said i was like
we will fly them out there uh
the name game's hard though
it it i thought yeah i thought they
would be real them off and forth but
then when i started thinking about it
like yeah okay
well let's both be in there just like
right here oh there he is
what up
what up brows
can you hear us or no
the guys i can hear you i can hear you
both man you have like the best wi-fi
there huh
wi-fi is pretty crispy and i do
appreciate the little browse t-shirt
oh bro always
support your boys that's a pretty dope
logo it is it's actually a really nice
uh is it an impact font nick
it is not impactful it's like more
narrow yeah
uh but yeah cool font is that would you
consider that your
logo um
i would someone made that for me shout
out to uh just merch they designed that
so that's the little browse logo yeah i
like it
uh so you're ducking me huh flew out of
town
had his chance to come back this week
training
really really smart because you're gonna
come in
one
or when we do it's gonna be one week
before my weight cut so i'm going to be
at the weakest so very smart strategy oh
my gosh i'll probably be about a hundred
seven way to nothing yeah but uh so
you're in atlanta right now
we're in georgia and we're lost in a way
or yeah bruh what up boston here what up
i wish we had a better setup
it looks dope dude i mean as far as your
computer or your phone yeah that would
have been cool
is this is the connection good it's
choppy on our end for whatever reason
it's fine we can we can hear you though
that's the most important part yeah it's
fine it's coming in and out
do you guys have an airbnb where are you
staying
give him a little tour yeah we just got
this sick airbnb it's like a cabin
uh
got the pool table right here
a little outside hot tub
oh it's sick
you got to wash your dryer we're in the
mountains in georgia
word are you shooting you're shooting
today for a music video
yeah you're supposed to be shooting
right now boys
we're coming to you from live on the
scene
perfect dude oh we're holding you up
yeah
he's getting set up right now and we're
about to shoot a video for our new song
called first flight so it's got like a
cabin vibe so we're up here in a cabin
and yeah it's going to be up here doing
our thing
oh yeah uh austin you're gonna have to
come in studio uh are you guys back next
week
i'm gonna call i'm gonna come to l.a
probably after browser's ohio show oh
nice nice yeah so back in studio you're
doing a weight cut nick uh that's right
uh
i'm i'm going to beat chin i'm going to
win 600 from um he's going to win for
sure
i've already lost uh i i saw 183 on the
scale yesterday so that was 16 pounds in
three weeks and
uh oh wow that's crazy i'm trying i'm
trying the goal is the goal is 155 after
uh after like the water load and stuff
we we had uh adrian from the ufc giving
me tips on weight cut and i've been
dming them
yeah just just yesterday started upping
my fiber so i'm [ __ ] a lot but
bought some fiber one cereal
and broccoli [ __ ] it i am moving
at 100 efficiency right now anything
that comes in is going out and i gained
five pounds so yeah it's over
and they started like catty the battery
over there huh yeah dude and then also
in in ohio we're gonna have time to eat
so
i'm gonna eat eating like crap load over
there for sure and drinking yeah i'm on
a two-day fast for this music video and
then brows wants to stop and grab a
whopper
about five minutes ago i had to just sit
there and smell him eating a whopper oh
my gosh man i didn't take brows as a
whopper guy i know he you see
you know someone in the car pointed it
out and i said one every three months
one every three to six months my issue
though is he's a single whopper not like
a double whopper if you're gonna go to
burger king splurge
you got to get a double like a big
whopper he's just got the single but
that's because brown is a skinny guy
she's not thinking like me
yeah a single whopper it's oh it's
basically an oxymoron like it's a small
whopper you want to you want a whopper
yeah
100 all right all right so
uh how long are you guys shooting are
you are you are there going to be video
hoes there where the hoes
this is the issue we're running into
yeah
this song is about
being at a cabin with girls pulling up
yep and it's basically just me and brown
are you guys on the tinder
i haven't been on tinder for a while
because i'm with my girlfriend but this
would be
oh we're in atlanta shooting a music
video swipe right if you want to come
through
easy right yep you would think so but
it's just us we're just gonna wear robes
and uh
perform back to back
okay okay uh you can leave it to the
imagination the hoes are off screen
i thought brows
we even need to make this a huge party
with like 50 girls right or there's no
in between or it's just me and him
yeah it looks like it's just you and him
or yeah if you could get two girls it
could be like a double date getaway at
the cabin
that is true right
a little swinger action
okay
maybe baby
did you guys even try to get girls no
what did you guys even try to get any
girls or no
no
yeah
it's all good just youtube
direct in our next video
i'm down i'm i'm i'm in uh well the only
idea they'll ever have is just get on
tinder right and let's just get a bunch
of girls
i feel like that's foolproof but if they
show up yeah yeah it is
it's just an excuse for nick to get on
tinder and he's like i know i miss him
it's been so long
uh i
does does the i or the app store show
when you download an app i don't think
you even think i could have it on and
delete it
don't just don't download it yeah yeah
yeah rather stay away but um well
anything else coming up guys or we'll
see you back in studio next week
yeah i think we're both gonna try to
come in soon when uh he's gonna come in
so we'll be there we'll do some cool
stuff we went to two chain studios the
other night i was oh
oh yes that was the that was the other
thing i wanted to ask you about uh
because right now we're in tuccin's
studio uh but you guys went to two
chains
pretty much same thing yeah uh what how
did that happen
so one of his friends uh just pulled up
to one of two chain sessions there and
they invited us like last minute so we
just hopped in the uber didn't ask any
questions next thing you know we're
playing basketball with two chains
and um they were in a studio session and
he's like telling us stories about lil
wayne and like it was just a legendary
legendary moment
kidney ball
i got a little sauce you got a little
lamb i started playing duffel bag and
telling the little wayne story i just
grabbed a bottle of tequila
stop
and then you know
might have you know caused some
interruptions but we got out of there
safe and sound everything's cool
i was too hyped up i was like this is
that is so cool legendary
yeah it was
yeah i mean that's one of the things you
live before i could see myself getting
uh yeah you're trying to enjoy this
moment a little bit too much and uh
did the two change drink or no
he was he was having a little i think
not too much but the thing is like the
fact he was getting kind of lit like we
got in there we were vibing and
everything but then it almost got a
little too crazy so we had to get out we
got right to the right
yeah uh didn't overstay your welcome
made the appearance can he ball that's
what i
could he play
yeah
i think he played in uh college he's
good oh damn good
and he's tall
that's that's super fun
uh what else do you have any more
questions for him jen i mean can we
preview anything now or no sweet
um preview the song yeah
yeah should i send it over you guys
could play a little sample right here
yeah
i will just play we don't have auto tune
right now so we can't sing it for you
guys i cannot yeah
don't worry the zoom audio even though
it'd be beautiful acapella i don't think
it would do it justice so if you want to
if you want to text them
we just sing it it's all choppy everyone
this is bro
if you want to text it to a christian
we'll we'll play it
oh yeah
chase you guys
okay
what's that
who else is in in the studio today same
crew same crew as always skeleton crew
it's me chin and christian
uh
we did do the uh first round of uh the
or like the play-in kind of contest to
get from nine people down to eight
people for the trivia contest that was
really fun we did name game who's been
on king of the sting and that's who
decided who went in it was pretty fun
you got named you got named
that's awesome
i love it we're doing a competition like
where fans basically we're seeing who
the biggest king in the sting fan is
trying to become more of an after show
nice
yeah
after nothing but yeah
keep the hook going but yeah it was fun
um i don't know we could play a song
later yeah we'll play the song we'll
we'll let you guys go uh excited to have
you back in studio and uh excited to
kick your ass yeah
oh [ __ ]
i just spat it nick you'll be
you'll be 150 pounds wither in a way i'm
not even worried i know george like
really nothing's nothing that is like
the upper echelon of all the fighters
here george yeah he went through that
survived that
that's not good dude that's true and i
had shin who was afraid to
lay his hands out so the next fight we
do we have to
go for it
yeah you guys got rematch we'll both be
in there soon we love you boys
we love you austin do you want to be on
the wheel the week before you come in
studio as a possible cats after dark
fight club participant
one thousand percent i love schneiderlin
that's that's the only answer we we
would have excited
for
100 down but i definitely i want some
type of promoter or something that's
going to fix the fight but we can work
something out so i can win 100
it's a it's a smart thing to try but i'm
afraid if you get matched up with me
it's going to be austin asleep
[Laughter]
i'm gonna have no brain fluid one shot
you'll concuss me you need a
wheelchair but uh well thanks guys i'm
gonna wait until you're at your weakest
state
that's what brazil is doing right now
it's genius
well thanks guys uh we'll talk to you
soon
see you guys in ohio later see you in
ohio oh yeah speaking of ohio forgot to
plug our freaking concert we're all
going to be there well now's the perfect
time it's time for time for plugs we
have a little shorter show but yeah
skeleton crew and we'll be back with
everybody in studio next week but uh
yeah tell us about it date it's
august 26th in portsmouth ohio i don't
know all the details but we all of us
have the links uh the link to the
tickets in our bio on our instagram so
go to little browse or chinsuyi or
austinawake is it the 19th day is it one
week from today it's literally next
friday oh next friday yeah yeah yeah so
a week from uh the release of this
episode so about a week yeah exactly
week dope uh go out and see those guys
get pictures um yeah hugs everything
yeah
jam out with them spar sessions
christian what what do you got uh just
instagram see palo 6 uh check out you
already know podcast with keenan
thompson and tandy morello on youtube
and that's about it wow
uh another podcast show check it out
that's uh my other passion project uh
we're doing some fun stuff on there i
just bought a live and i'm gonna uh go
around um
uh like around my neighborhood to like
some of the more homeless encampments
with like a gopro in my head and just
kind of like have you ever seen bill
bird drive around la yeah uh and he just
kind of comments and stuff i'm gonna do
that but more for homeless encampments
and actually talking to them uh
if i if i see approachable ones but
it'll more just be be doing commentary
from afar interesting because it's not
like i don't know some people basically
say it sounds insensitive but you should
see the communities that are going on
there they're not they're not homeless
people they're like drug deads and stuff
i walked past one the other day and like
this guy like brought out a flute and i
swear to god he was alerting
of my presence he was like he like i
started to walk under this bridge and he
said oh you see his head speaking out
like
uh so
that's that's the kind of stuff we do on
another podcast show
um
yeah
that's it go uh we're next weekend the
trivia uh contest starts full full swing
that'll be really fun the winner will be
flying to los angeles and get to sit in
on a day of spirit airlines uh thick boy
production probably see a king in the
sting cats after dark
anything else going on that day
and uh yeah for
the rest of the guys austin george
george kyle casey
everybody else chris shows up
get gianni in here we watch gianni in
studio next week um i can see what i can
do he's he he's he's talent now so like
he's tough to work with toughness locked
down you know i think i i have a better
chance of reaching out than you do yeah
100 with him but yeah but he said he he
said in the past he would come on
but i feel like if you ask him he'll say
yes because if i ask him he'll just tell
me to shut the [ __ ] up so
same thing
that could go that way but hopefully
he'll be in here soon too trevor too we
always forget about you oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah trevor for
sure producer next time you guys yeah
like when you drop
next project for sure
well thanks guys we'll be here next week
and thanks for tuning in
[Music]
[Music]
you